Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
Live.
I'm your host, Rawkode.
Today
is clustered,
the thing I hate every single week, but
oddly enough, kind of enjoy having fun fixing
broken Kubernetes clusters.
So I'm gonna be joined today by Marcos.
I'll introduce him in just a moment, but
we are gonna attempt to fix two Kubernetes
clusters. The catch is they are broken by
members of the Kubernetes community. I will introduce
each cluster
as we start it and hopefully as we
fix them.
A little bit of housekeeping before we begin.
Please, if you're not subscribed to the YouTube
channel, do that now. Click the bell, get
notifications
every time a new episode goes live.
I make it part of my role and
I'm, you know, supported by my employer, Equinix
Medal, to produce cloud native cloud native learning
materials so that we can all learn this
vast landscape together.
There's also a very active Discord channel. There's
a couple of hundred people in there now.
We're talking about cloud native. We're talking about
Kubernetes, and we're talking about technology, Rust, Go,
loads of cool stuff. Feel free to pop
out there. If you're not watching live, it
is the best way to ask questions
about any cloud native technology
and to suggest new episodes. Win win.
And thank you to my employer. Again, they
sponsor my time to do this. You can
try out Equinix metal. It is a bare
metal cloud with $50 code Rawkode live. This
will get you around one hundred hours of
compute. So, you know, use that as wisely
or unwisely as you want, but small instance,
big instances, whatever. Have some fun.
Alright. My cohost today is Marcos Niles, a
software engineer in the gaming industry and
all round container and Kubernetes ecosystem member. Marcos,
why don't you tell us a little bit
about yourself, please?
Thanks, David. David, welcome everyone to another episode
of Cluster.
My name is Marcos Niels. As David correctly
said, I'm a software engineer at WiLi Studios.
It's it's a gaming company.
And I've been in the cloud native world,
like, for several years already since early early
stages of Docker.
I've co contributed
and co authored play with Docker.com and .com,
which are, like, online based
environments where you can try and play with
open Kubernetes.
And happy to be here. Looking forward to
see what the cluster breakers brought us today.
Looking forward is a bold word, but I
like the optimism. So let's just get started
on cluster number
oh, this is number 17.
Wow.
Good fun. Alright. We have as always teleport.
Marcus and I both have access. I am
going to quickly click connect on the control
plane of this cluster.
If you can join that session and give
us a little echo hello to confirm that
you are here.
Will Getting there. Do that thing where I
resize
the bottom because we always cut it off
and it's super annoying
And I will introduce the breaker of this
cluster. This cluster is broken by Sasha Grenard,
who is the SIG release
co chair or chair. I can't remember. Yeah.
Chair. SIG release chair
involved in the Kubernetes security space
and just all around general awesome Kubernetes contributors.
So thank you, Sasha for taking the time
to break this cluster. I can see that
Marcos has given me a smiley face,
which means we are ready to start.
I don't know if you've watched one of
these before. I think you have, but it's
always nice to start with an optimistic
get pods, get nodes and see if we
have any access to the control plane. So
why don't we just
why don't we configure We need to do
all the Yeah. All the bootstrap right here.
All the board and bits. So we'll get
Kube control working. I'll set up the Kube
config, and then I'll I'll give you the
orders of typing whatever Kubernetes command you want
to see if we have access.
The stage is all yours. Go for it.
So here we go.
So let's try to get notes.
Oh, it's fixed. We can move to the
other one. Right?
I wish it was that that easy.
Okay. So note theme, apparently, they seem to
be ready, which is cool.
First thing that I'm gonna do, David, because
we have been beaten by this is this.
Okay. This is very nice.
Yeah. Because, you know, we haven't beaten by
this before. But in any case, let's try
to see the port status. So let's try
to see all ports in the cluster.
Everything seems to be running, which is
Sorry. I I broke it. Went to the
other screen.
I need to remember Yeah. I need to
remember to hit control r on the right
screen.
There we go. No worries.
So it seems like pretty much all the
bots are ready. So let's see on the
default main space, what do we get?
Apparently,
everything's to be everything seems to be fine.
So I
think we're gonna find some issues regarding communication
communication with the bot, maybe networking related stuff.
I think we need to try port forwarding
and see if we can access the service
at this point since everything seems to be
okay.
It it does look like a working cluster.
Right? I mean It seems to me. Yeah.
No.
Okay. Well We can try to see the
the service maybe.
We can try to see
the service of
cluster.
It's going endpoint. Endpoint? Yeah. So seems to
be okay, Adam. I would just try port
forwarding and see what we get. Alright. Let
me pull up over a terminal. It's a
bit easier to do that from here.
And I have my Rawkode cluster directory
with cluster 17
export to kube config
and just make sure I can run get
pods.
Yes. Okay. So let's do port forward.
Custard.
Itty. Itty. Itty.
Our cost is working.
Ah, see. I told you. Nothing to fix
here.
So that's definitely
interesting.
Let's try the upgrade
just in case. So
if we can yeah. Good call. Let's do
an edit on that deployment and see if
we can modify the image, see if it
works.
And you should just be able to change
it to version. V two. Right? Yeah.
Oh. Oh, okay. Okay. Now.
Now was starting to worry there that this
was a someone had forgotten to break a
cluster, but it looks like It was
going to be way to easy.
So let's see.
Oh, to copy and paste this, I need
to use
insert and shift insert. Right? Yeah. Control and
insert and shift and insert should keep you
Yeah. Keep you going. So
back off
failed container.
Hunk. Oh, OCI runtime creates unknown hunk. Oh,
interesting.
I there's just never any shortage of honks
on this. Let's show that's what's here. Yeah.
So the first thing that I would do
is I would try to I don't know
the
image pool policy that we have here.
So
let's see the
edit, deploy,
cluster,
image pool policy always, so seems to be
okay. This is the right address, I believe.
Right?
That is correct. Yes.
So let's maybe we can try
creating just a
raw,
like, a raw pod, a raw deployment to
see if that's gonna fail also. I I'm
just trying to see if we see the
same thing on, like, a regular deployment or
just on this deployment because maybe this deployment
has a specific configuration.
Oh, makes sense. Maybe let's let's do k
run image NGINX
NGINX.
Get bots.
Container creating.
And running. Oh, so it's running. Interesting because
this this means that this is only affecting
this specific deployment.
So what could affect the deployment within our
cluster? Okay. I'm thinking maybe two things right
now.
I'm thinking admission controllers perhaps.
Okay.
K. Get
admission controllers.
I need to be valid.
If you've got complete, that's gonna help. But
validating web admission,
whatever that big long thing is
or type API resources. Yeah.
Yeah. I I can never remember the name
of it.
Yeah. It's way too long. Let's do a
rep.
Okay.
K. Get validating.
It's not completing for me.
We'll try and fix that. Do it at
the end.
Dash a. I don't know if these are
yeah. They are not nothing here. We can
try mutating.
Yeah. Let's try the mutating one.
Webhook
configuration.
Just in case. Interesting.
Interesting. Because it seems like since this is
only affecting this
this deployment let's see the the deployment, though.
Let's see if we see something funny there.
Yeah. Good call.
And we accept suggestions from the audience.
Strategy, nothing weird.
Metadata,
labels. We could try changing the label because
maybe something watching that as label and doing
something funky.
That shouldn't affect
anything in particular.
We have the
protocol,
the image resources seem to be okay.
Mhmm.
Termination
message policy. The end policy seems to be
okay. Default scheduler seems to be okay. Reset
quality okay.
Yeah. I don't see anything
weird here.
Shall we go take a look at the
so there's also static admission controllers, which would
be configured on the the
Oh. On on the manifests on the API
server or Kubla. I can't remember which, but
we should probably go check if any of
those have been turned on.
Yes, sir.
Queue.
But look, I have suggested that are all
complete isn't working because of the alias.
Yeah. We'll check that in a second. You
might be right.
No. So the only admission plugin is node
restriction,
which is which is fine. I would expect
to see that there.
No authorization. No. No. That's oh, it's this
one. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So that there's no
restriction one that is fine. That's pretty standard
Yep. That I remember.
Let's see if these files were changed.
Good call.
They didn't seem to have it changed. They
have not changed. Yeah.
Yeah.
So this is someone suggested something on the
on the test.
We are because they
Waleed is suggesting we take a look at
container d and see if the configuration for
that has been modified in any way.
That would make sense. The the error message
that we've seen that say that it was
an OCI container runtime problem.
So
Yeah.
It was on a t c. I think
it was container e dot tunnel.
Yeah. It doesn't have
to exist. So
you might wanna do a system control cat
container d and see if there's any overlays
on that. Yeah.
I don't seem to
see anything here. No. That looks good. Maybe
on
system,
system d,
container e,
Find dot container
e.
Maybe here. Let's see.
Yeah. I think at this stage, I'll look
at everything. Yeah.
Same thing as we saw before.
Nothing
that's that's that's what tells
all the way around.
The inner key.
Nothing.
Looks good.
Yeah. I don't see anything weird here.
Can we see the header message again?
The error on the, yeah, on the deployment?
Yeah. So I need to It looks like
our pod. Did our pod go away?
Maybe it rolled
back to the other no. It didn't. Oh,
is it running now?
Where's the Oh, it's running. Where's the crash
loop back off?
Yeah. That We have nothing. It'd fine. An
intermittent error.
Let's put it
So it pulled and it started.
I mean, that honk is that's that's injected.
Right? This that that was not an intermittent
error. That's intended
Yeah. To attach. Honk unknown.
That's weird. OCR runtime create sale Hong Kong
known.
However, we didn't get that on the on
the other one.
Let me let's try
changing the deployment label,
but that's gonna affect the service. Right? So
we need to change the service as well.
Why why don't we try and downgrade the
container back to version one and see if
we get the same error again? Just to
confirm that it's affecting only this
this deployment.
Image. That's the thing. Sometimes the breakers,
their intended breakage can be a little bit
subtle
and that honk in the error message is
is gonna annoy me, so I wanna get
to the bottom of it.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. The comp thing is, like,
very mysterious.
Alright. So that just worked. Let's try upgrading
it again to v two.
K. Get pods. This is okay.
V one.
V two.
Yeah. Same thing. Okay.
So it
seems to potentially be either in the same
But now it's running. Yeah. It's intermittent.
Describe
both. I I think
Alright. Let
What do we We looked at all the
static manifest. Can we take a look at
the kubelet unit file?
If that's been modified in some way. Feeling
that, I think we need take a random,
save the control plane somewhere.
Well, have I lost you?
I'm talking to myself. All right. Okay. I'll
do some typing just now until
Rawkode is back.
So
let's see.
I don't like subtle errors
because
oh, almost like Marcus is potentially still typing.
At least I can communicate through the power
of Teleport. Thank you.
Alright. Marcos can hear me. So we'll continue
for now.
I am gonna take a look at this
system, the unit fail for the Qiplet.
And see if something's been passed in that
I don't expect to see.
Marcus has now dropped. Maybe maybe I'll be
back in a minute.
So it's oh, hey. You're back.
Okay. Let's see. Go keep the restart always
blah blah blah. Boding. Boding. Boding.
Can you hear me? I can hear you.
Hello. Hi. Sorry. I'm back.
Yeah. I'm I'm just
trying to see if I can spot any
of it. Right now, I'm
thinking there's something
weird with the
queue, but just because the static manifest haven't
been modified, container d doesn't have a config.
We haven't looked to see what node the
pod has been scheduled on to see if
that affects, like, where the NGINX one was
scheduled versus where the clustered one was scheduled.
Perhaps one of the worker nodes has been
called. Oh,
yeah. Maybe one of the
cubelets in the worker nodes are yeah. That
would be the case.
Have the CRI the the CRI runtime change?
It's not container e and it's something else.
It's like a honk binary or something. Yeah.
It's just these are these things are difficult
to work out when they're subtle and intermittent,
but it looks like NGINX ran just fine
on
this FFST.
Our clustered one is on that running fine.
I wonder if the failed ones were scheduled
to other node potentially. Although, I don't think
a restart should reschedule it, if my understanding
is correct.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's why maybe it's working
now because it's landing into that node, basically.
Right? So maybe what we can do is
we can go to that node and bring
down the unit so the pods get rescheduled
and see what happens.
That's a good idea. Okay. Let's pop open
FFFT
eight and I will shut down the Kubelet.
Oh, I wanna drain it first one so
that we actually see the
it is key. Yeah.
Yeah. We can just just drain the node
as well. Right? Or like Oh, yeah. I
can do that from here. Yeah. We could
just call it on the node and then
see if I Yep.
I was gonna try and do it from
the node itself. That would be silly. There
we go.
And the little parts
and then drain it. Yeah. Just drain it.
Yeah.
No. Demon sets.
I thought Drain would reschedule that already.
Oh, because of the I think we've got
a
storage error. Right?
Cannot delete ports managed by
We can use ignore daemon
sets.
Yeah.
When in doubt.
Blue dash nine.
I hope we haven't scaled the only working
noise. We broke everything pretty much. Right? Yeah.
Alright. We got yeah. Things are affecting now.
Okay. Let's see what happens now. We can
always we can always I I think the
the the maybe restarting the development should have
been easier because now we have all these
folks that are not gonna be able to
get scheduled. Right?
Yeah. Rawkode and Seth is gonna be mighty
unhappy with me. That's a good point.
Yeah. It is what it is. Yeah. It
wouldn't be a a clustered episode if I
didn't make stuff worse before we fixed it
properly. So, yeah, I'm I'm getting used to
it now.
And we don't have to watch we didn't
look Sorry. You go. One thing we didn't
look at is if there there are any
row pods in the cluster. Right? Because we
maybe there's something weird running. I don't know.
That's a good shot. Yeah.
So it's running on that node.
Shall we
change?
One one thing that is is weird, David,
is that this only happened when we bumped
to v two. Right? When we were using
v one.
When we rolled back to v one, we
didn't get that error. Right? We didn't get
any restarts, I believe.
Not that I saw. You're right.
Let's
let's bring that note back just so Rick
and Seth won't yell at us too much.
If we just uncoordinate
and then we can start let's test your
hypothesis.
We'll downgrade cluster then up on it again
and see.
We need some code on this one. Right?
Yes.
And that should get Rick and Seth at
least to stop warning us.
Pending. Pending. Okay. This should be okay. Let's
see if we get any
yeah. We don't get any errors on this
one. So
it's definitely something,
like,
looking at this deployment.
I see a raw workload.
Speaker? No. That's That's metal l b at
the node debugger.
Node debugger.
So that is not ours? It's definitely not
not part of a standard cluster API cluster.
No.
It's the only thing that looks
different.
Is it a
it's not an RF. It's a bot.
It's, like, twenty
nine hours ago, so it seems like it
could be a role thing.
It's a it's a.
Seems like. Right? Oh, there's three of them.
Yeah. So potentially a. Yeah.
Don't see it as a. Right? Alright. Must
be a deployment just with replica set to
three.
I didn't see it twice in at least
in QC.
We're gonna have to describe it then. Let's
describe one of the pods and see if
we can get some information out of there.
To me. So let's do
k.
This is.
System.
Describe bot.
What
do we have here?
Priority zero.
This is out time. It terminated.
Seems like they are just Thunderbots.
Weird.
I mean, it's got a host path mode
on of root. That's not good.
Oh, I didn't see it. Oh, this is
yeah. Definitely not good. Let's delete this card.
Well, I I'm I'm just I'm do we
want to delete it?
I mean, I made this mistake before.
Should we jump on it and look at
the the bash history or something?
You want to check on this and see
what what's what's in here?
I I don't know. I I don't know.
This? Yeah. Let's let's let's do some debugging.
Right? Let's let's go inside about that. The
the image seems to be seems to be,
like, a standard Alpine image. Right? So it's
not something funky here.
Yes. But if we at least go into
the container, we can go into the proc
file system. Oh, no. Because I've got the
whole root one. Depends on the namespace.
Like, what I'm curious about is is it
running any commands on my host right now?
So that's why I don't want to delete
it. Let's do a p s a u
x But see we can see something rogue.
I don't know. What what is this even
running? Because it's oh, maybe
they created this. That's it.
So Nuno is asking, who is the villain?
That would be Sasha at.
So we can do exec
system exec dash t I. We can go
to the one that is that is running,
which is this one. Yeah. While while I
need to suggest on the same as me,
we should be taking a look at that
shell history and see what our sneaky
sneaky people have been up to.
Oh, this is in the okay. In the
feed namespace,
the same feed namespace at the at the
host
for what I see.
What do you see? Sorry. I I think
I'm a little bit behind you. I'm inside
the I'm inside the pod,
the container basically on that pod. Oh, so
it's I mean, same feed namespace as as
host. So this is like a privilege. Yeah.
I was worried about using host pad. Okay.
So it's got host
path route. It's got host pad.
Is definitely It's on
yeah. On host.
What's that key.service?
Where?
/host/key.service.
Let's take a look at that. That's
that looks new.
Slash host/k.service.
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Oh, Bing k. Yeah. This is something definitely
interesting.
What is this Bing k?
I'm hoping there's gonna be a shell script
with a shebang. Should we go peek at
it?
Do we have five here? No. That's it.
But it's on the host path. We can
probably jump we could probably jump out.
Oh, yep.
So
I'm gonna get outside here, there.
Uh-huh.
Oh,
yeah. This is messing up with
yeah. So it basically
oh, randomly kills containers. It's like another way
of doing Chrome tab. Nice.
See? It was about Chrome tab. Yep. So
it's an I just wanna connect
it to speak to container d that is
just running a kill command.
Got it. Yeah. Run c and it's
randomly
then killing
the container, basically.
Okay. I think if we kill the node
debugger
pods.
How would you call the the service?
It was I think it's being called from
that node debugger service.
It's this one. Right? K. Yes.
Status k. So we can do system c
t l disable k. But it's not running,
though. When when is this running?
And we we can do stop k.
Okay. This is not running.
So and we can I guess we can
delete the
The node DB drive? Right?
Now that we know what they're doing. But
we don't know how they're there unless they're
just pods that are named sneakily to look
like other objects.
Yeah.
Shall we delete them?
Yeah. I think they're gonna come back. I
think they're in the static manifest directory with
a
hidden somehow. That's fine. Delete.
But
Goodbye.
Oh, I forgot the grace period.
Hopefully,
you might need to force it depending on
especially since that one's on interstate.
Goodbye. Let's see if if it come back
before doing this because
system.
Oops.
Get caught.
It didn't come back?
Yeah. It didn't come back. So let's go
with the other one.
Okay.
And the last one is in error. Do
you want to leave it here just in
case for the sake of, you know, life?
Or
Kubernetes is an error state. Can we see
the logs? Do you have previous on it
so we can get anything out of it?
Or even just check the logs of the
running one.
I
guess this is cache.
Did I type
Wrong namespace. Oh, no. It's right namespace.
No. It's okay.
Two fifty logs.
Yeah. That's right. Dash. Dash p after logs.
Yeah. Dash dash previous dash p, I think.
Go for it. Exchange that says not found.
Weird.
I don't know why it's saying Where's the
schedule? Let's do it. Dash o white.
Sounds good.
Let's see if then get four dash o
white.
S two. Two g l v. Let's pop
on s two.
Oh, we're on s two. That's the control
plan.
Oh,
firewall.
VarLock. Right. VarLock containers.
This is called node. Right? Node debugger. Yeah.
That's there. Yeah.
Can't know debugger.
Oh, it's basically what I did on the
on the on the scene, I believe.
Oh, demon reload. Oh, we have the evidence
now, so we can chase the criminal.
So there's some daemon reload stuff here
and system CTL enabled now. Okay.
So,
yeah, it's like
I think that's it. I think we much.
Yeah. Yeah.
Sorry. Let's
let's see if we get the same
Yeah. Go for it. K get pods.
Edit, deploy,
clustered.
Let's go to image here.
View let's do v one again.
I don't know if the
breakers are on the
on the chat, but it's I don't know
if there's anything else we should be looking
at. I believe Billy is here. I've seen
a comment earlier. I haven't seen that offer
from Sasha, so I'm assuming that he's not
available.
But let's see if we running,
And let's go back to v two.
Yeah. If we can upgrade this, I'm gonna
assume that the case service was the
I don't know how that was gonna honk
there though.
Seems like it's
running just fine. Seems like
I don't know where the conk was coming
from. Yeah. You're right.
I think that's fixed.
I mean I think objective is for us
to be able to upgrade the application, browse
to it.
It's running. I mean, I could do the
port forward.
We did check the static manifest, Malik. We've
never seen anything nefarious.
The only thing Static, but we didn't see
any changes on the static manifest. Right? Yeah.
Nothing nothing had changed. We sent it an
all host while it's it's it's
He's telling us to be thorough.
And Billy has said, hey. Hey, Billy.
Alright. Let's just for completeness,
we will jump on to each of the
worker nodes, and we will check the
the static manifest. Yeah. Billy, your cluster is
coming up in a minute.
Sound good.
I'm
following you.
Yeah. I think Sasha's just
modified
the thing we we we think. I'm feeling
confident.
Could be. Yeah.
I'm
I'm counting this as a win. I say
we move on to the next cluster. Sasha
can let us know and has write up
if we missed anything.
The honk is bugging me slightly, but the
objective is I agree. To upgrade our application
and
I and we haven't browsed it, but I
will do that for completeness.
So
Let's let's do one more thing.
I I'm wondering if
the hunk is still there, but only when
it tries to schedule the port in one
specific node because one worker node was particularly
you know?
Do we have pods in all the nodes,
by the way? Sorry. Can you say that
again? K.
Get pods.
If we have pods in all nodes in
all nodes.
Maybe there's a particular node that it's not
scheduling anything. No. We have pods in all
nodes, so it doesn't seem to be a
container y
Yeah. The data set is running. There's stuff
running everywhere. Oh, yeah. Yeah. You're right. Yep.
Yep. Great. Alright. I don't know what else
to do. Yeah.
I'm gonna just
check if there's been anything deployed to here
that
would be not part of my standard cluster
API cluster.
But
Yeah. That's the thing though. Like, Sasha is
involved in in security and sec comp and
all this weird stuff that I wish I
understood even 10%
that he did. So there's there are so
many subtle things he could have done to
this cluster, and I don't wanna go chasing
them
just because we think that they're
nothing's broken.
It seems to be working. Unless someone has
any recommendations on where to look at for
the honk thing.
Well, it is always full of suggestions. He's
telling us to scale our cluster thing. So
let's make that the call. If we can
scale clustered to every node on this cluster,
we that's it. It's fixed.
Alright? Sounds good. Yep. I
think Waleed suspects there's something else, but I
mean, I think we all do. But it's
if we don't see it, we don't see
it.
There
it is.
How you doing on y to see what
it got scheduled?
Maybe we can catch it.
No. It got oh,
they all went to the same note. That's
weird.
Alright.
Well, it's should never have listened to you.
Okay. Let's go back then.
Yeah. I have been yeah. Seems like it's
I think one node is particularly
That's the thing. Right? No.
I was gonna say, like, that that system
service that we run-in the kill containers,
we stopped that. So when we get a
run container error, that's confusing me.
Alright. Let's do
So that's on our control plane. Oh, it's
the same node. Yeah. Yes.
Node, like f f f f s t
eight.
Why why only the
yeah. OCI runtime,
create field, honk, unknown. Damn honk.
It's weird because it's a it's a warning
on the on the
Kubernetes event. Right? It's not a it's not
not an error.
Fails to create pod sandbox.
Onk.
OCR one config.
Save honk and known.
So
It has to be container d.
Something
Container d or the
kubelet.
Shall we check out the kubelet config? We
didn't check that, right, on the system d.
Okay. Yeah. Let's go into
you you wanna go into that FF worker.
Right? So we can do
oh, it's in that, yeah, in that worker
only.
I I think I want to do something.
I would like to call on that node
specifically and scale up the the deployment to
see if it happens on the other note
as well. Because I don't know if it's
it's only that note or all of them,
basically, that one container error.
Just scale it. Just scale it to 30
replicas and then run a wide watch, and
we'll see if it happens on others. And
we can always grip that if we want
just to filter.
So
replica.
Let's see. Alright. Just go to stupid number.
These are big machines.
K. Get both slash all white.
Container creating.
Had detailed Yeah.
There's an error here. Oh, yeah. It seems
like it's happening in all nodes. Yep.
Yeah.
Okay. So
replicas.
We can come back to three. I don't
know.
So
let's see
let's see the
queue. Let's configuration on any of the worker
nodes. Right?
Yes. Okay.
Let's I'm on
FFST
eight if you wanna join this session.
I'm gonna go there.
Join session. I'm there.
Okay. So we've got a pretty standard unit
file.
Let's take a Yeah.
Yeah. We should see a config on the
environment file.
Like, both path. Yeah.
That looks normal. So
Of course, didn't that weird thing. Okay.
Oh, sorry. I was just gonna do a
cat on the No, it's no worries. On
the Kubelet thing again and see and just
walk her Oh, I'm doing the wrong file.
And just walk our way through these files.
So we've also got
how do I do We have the page.
Do I mean
there we go.
Oh, maybe we can check the logs of
the Qubelet. Something
might pop up there.
Yeah. Or even the container d logs might
actually be a good shot too.
I always forget the logs are a thing.
Alright. So
let's do a journal
container d.
Continue and time to get drivers.
I mean, I see adders, but nothing that
nothing that helps.
Hey. You wanna see the There's a
runtime
class in Kubernetes. Right?
Runtime class name, which is basically specifies the
CRI to use.
Third. I know if we check that that
resource.
Okay.
So why cluster?
Yeah. I don't think anything is
configured there. Oh, I'm on the workers. Yeah.
I'm gonna try to go to the master
to the control plane.
K. API resources.
Web
runtime.
K. Get
runtime classes.
Nothing here.
How is he getting nothing? Do do we
take the the QLED locks on on the
worker?
Yeah. They're pretty noisy from Rawkode and Seth.
Oh, yeah.
Try searching for hunk,
maybe.
I need to take the follow-up if I
Oh,
yeah.
Alright. There we go.
Okay. So it's actually affecting all containers. We
can see it on staff
containers here too.
Yeah.
Do I'm wondering if
system CDL
I'm wondering if we have, like, a system
d service here. Maybe that's also,
like
I don't even know.
There's nothing in Kubernetes. I think we're confident
enough in that. Yeah. The control plane seems
to be healthy. I think something has to
be happening on a host.
But I'm curious if we've got any
We have okay. Yeah.
Hunk.
No.
Maybe there's the binary somewhere.
I can recall if there's there's any configuration
we can do,
like, by putting it in files that changes
the CRI of the of the QLED.
Because the queue list just stops to container
e and
I'm
not sure. Audience, what you got for us?
Come on.
We'll give this another few minutes and then
we'll move on to the other cluster. And
if we have time, we'll look back. I
don't wanna
spend all of our time on one, but
whatever Sacha whatever Sacha has hidden is
is good.
Let's do system d.
Yeah. It's a good comment from both then.
Oh, so we have the k we have
the k stuff here as well.
Sorry. What was that?
We have the k system d service here
as well.
On the on the worker?
On the worker. Yes.
Here it is.
I wanna check the container the binaries.
Yeah. I actually ran a Witch container the
other and and run fail on it, and
I kinda
assumed that was Yeah. This is okay.
Yeah. It's I think that's okay.
Oh, I don't know if we had here
on the on the other notes,
the continuity comp.
No. It was it's okay.
Yeah. It is okay.
I don't think container d is,
you know, why
I don't know.
It's the same idea of status container d.
Do we see something here? We don't. Right?
Let's
look at.
I don't know.
Okay.
Container.
I'm locked, man. I don't know where I
have to look.
Maybe we could always do the break glass
button,
which is to go to the root fail
system, do a thing by modified in the
last twenty four hours. But I don't wanna
reach to that point of desperation.
But
yeah. No config here. So something should be
Okay. Let's jump over to cluster 18.
If we have time, we will Now good.
Maybe something will come to us as as
we move on. But right now,
I don't know where that honk is coming
from.
Sneaky snapshot. It's big game. I'm serious.
Alright. I'm gonna close cluster 17 and we
will come back to it.
Alright.
Oh, yeah. This is 18 and that's yeah.
Okay. Got it. Let me just shut that
down.
Okay. So this cluster, cluster 18 is broken
by Billy Cleek from Digital Ocean. Thank you,
Billy, who is also available in the chat
if we also get stumped.
I popping open the control plane. We will
get the basic setup. You jump in and
then we'll check and see what we are
working with.
I'm getting there.
Joining now.
What's the completion? Source.
Source,
you forgot the minus sign.
Yep.
And there should be a minus sign in
in front of the yeah. There.
Like, the
open
open thing, the this one.
Oh, yeah. Of course. Less less time. Yeah.
Yeah. Basically, that one.
Cool. So you wanna do the honors?
Yep. Billy's wishing his luck. That's
a good start. Thank you, Billy. No control
plane. Of course. Oh, of course.
Yeah. Actually, think and I prefer when I
don't have a control plane because I know
where to start looking. I know what we
need to check.
Okay. No APIs ever running.
Please please don't mess with the CD. No.
It's really running like
okay.
We should check the manifest. Right? We should
check the manifests.
Of course, they were modified
because
YOLO.
Let's see QLED
system.
CTL.
That's QLED.
K. QLED seems to be running.
Error updating of status.
There seems to be some errors in the
logs.
Yeah. If you add that no pager to
that, you'll be oh, you can just scroll
this side to it. Yeah.
So let's check the
the S3 first.
So SCD,
should we check the
logs first? Oh, yeah. The fact that the
manifest exists,
I wanna know why the process isn't running.
So, yeah, I think getting a lot Yeah.
Probably a good start.
Okay.
Let's go tell.
There we go.
Received
terminated scene now. Shine down.
It's static, basically.
Create transport fails. Couldn't connect to itself.
This just could be a misconfiguration
then.
Reconnecting.
Interesting. Let's restart the Cubelets to see
because it seems like it it didn't fail
to start up. Right? It it started up,
and then it received the Oh, terminal. Oh,
yeah. Second one. Yeah.
Let's
restart container d Tulip?
I mean, I've done that before, and it's
led to bigger problems. I'm just throwing that
out there. You'd be warned.
YOLO.
So it's really running now.
But for how long?
Looks alright. Yeah.
You wanna cut the lights? Maybe it's gonna
shut down
eventually
for some reason.
Maybe a cron tap. No. I need to
check. Yeah. Yeah. I need to do it,
you know, just for the
is API server running? No.
Okay. The API server is not running.
But,
actually, it seems to be okay so far.
So Can you tell the logs? Shall we
go
we'll go.
Cut.
See. Oh, I have two, right, which is
the new one.
Let's do Pick one and see.
It's the second one. Right?
The HCT c one. This one. Yeah. Seems
to be okay. That is one healthy HCT.
Cool. Yeah. Let's do that. The API server.
Queue API server.
Oh,
what am I missing? Which is the last
one? Can't
have etcd.
Although those logs are five minutes old, so
it's not restarted when you restarted the Kubelet.
It didn't?
Well, based on those logs, no. I don't
believe it's been running for the last six
minutes.
Maybe did I oh, I I got the
the old API
server.
It's
this one is the last one. Right?
Yep. That's the right one. Quora admission added.
Okay. That that's the last one. I need
Do we see an error here?
Because seems to be okay. Right?
Looking. Looking. Looking.
Looks like we have our web work configured
for local hosts, but I think there's either
maybe an impression controller plug in that doesn't
exist enabled.
Oh. Let's go check the API server manifest.
Sounds good.
And we have admission plugins, no restriction,
etcd servers.
We need to check if etcd is listening
here, which I believe it we It was
here. Believe. A lot of this is okay.
Preferred address.
I believe this is okay.
Yeah. That looks fine.
At a first glance, I don't see anything
weird here.
We should check that we are using the
right images maybe, though
the API server seems to be okay.
Yep.
So why the why the API server is
not starting, though? That's the main
let's see.
Oh, it is running now.
Alright. Okay. Let's try to get notes.
Okay.
Are we in the right cluster, David?
Yeah. We are. 018?
Okay.
And the port
seems to be running.
So
can you try accessing that service at least
in the beginning to make sure that
I'm
gonna be monitoring this, but
weird.
Please, we need not another phone when
we are
updating the service.
Uh-huh. With no networking.
Okay.
So
So let's check the endpoints on the service
before we start diving into networking, I think.
Describe
service
chapter. Right? Correct. Oh, post Postgres. Right? We
need to
it's called Yeah. Check both. Yeah.
Looks good. So the endpoint is there. The
port seems to be okay, I believe.
That's correct. Yeah. So
looks like it's networking.
So what we can, yeah, what we can
do
is the Postgres running
an actual database.
If the application just tries to connect through,
like, standard
JDBC or,
like
Yeah. It's just a database driver? Postgres driver
over that port TCP layer. Pretty standard. Yeah.
So let's see
let's see the
oh, the the bot seems seem to be
running since the the same date.
Why don't we jump inside the cluster container
and see if we can hit the Google
and stuff like that? Let's see it. Let's
write off a few things first before we
Yeah. Okay. Good old rabbit hole.
What am I missing?
Oh, I lost the
wait. It's not pasting my okay.
This is the bot
and hash.
You're in you're inside the container already.
Oh, it worked. I don't know. Yeah. Okay.
It's just the node name and the container
name is is ridiculous.
It's on there.
We have an NS lookup. No. Is it
a minor?
I think I've been to. Yeah. You got
it. Okay.
Which one is it? Net utils?
No. You're oh, look at that with no
DNS. Oh, that's all yeah. That's all DNS.
Oh, I don't have ping also. Okay. You
do have ping, but try it. Yeah.
Okay. So it's just DNS. Oh, okay. Right.
And
that's the right IP address? Yeah. So let's
check the core DNS the Kube DNS service
on the Kube system namespace. Yeah. Let's go
back here.
Oh, we didn't check out the pod. Right?
So seems to be running. Look at they
all look at all those restarts.
It's CD cluster control plane.
Yeah.
Yeah. HTT is not happy, but that's not
our biggest problem right now. Our biggest problem
right now is DNS. So
Yeah. It's nothing compared to that. It has
one restart.
Do I just Oh, let's see the
yeah. I was gonna say say describe the
Kube DNS service. Let's see if we've got
some endpoints
there.
Sounds good.
Kube system.
That service, it's
Uh-huh.
Oh, I forgot an f. Wait a minute.
Okay.
And now we can do describe.
Endpoints.
Endpoints seems to be there.
We
have the metrics endpoint, the DNS endpoint, which
is okay. Shall we see the configuration for
QDNS, maybe?
I really hope someone hasn't modified the
config again.
Call DNS.
So
this is c name in Google.com.
Yeah. This seems to be
Yeah. This is There
you go. There's the problem. N x domain.
So, basically, for any
any, you you return an n x domain
resolution. So we need to change that that
one.
Alright. Let's get that fixed up.
Well, he called that as well. Good call.
How
was the name?
Hey.
Okay. So this one
goes This
one goes away.
That's it. Right?
I think it is. Unicode is banned, Balid.
No one will ever mess me up with
Unicode. Let's
restart the bot.
Shall we do a rollout?
I
might as well do it the nice way.
So now
we start
to DNS. What's the service?
Core DNS. Yeah.
And restart service. Deploy. Deploy. Right? Or is
it yeah. Yeah. There it is.
Depots.
So It's it can take thirty seconds.
I normally just delete them.
Yeah. That's appropriate.
Especially if we're having an SCD problems.
Reports,
and I can do
dash l a p p call unit or
QVNS.
Oh. You've got get get pods.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Get pods dash l a
p p.
It's
I think it's gate gate set.
Which one? Oh,
this one. Like this?
No. Do mind if I type?
Yep. Go ahead. I think the core Kubernetes
services are
Okay.
There's something. Okay. Oh, there you go. So
delete them. Go for it.
And just for
Oh,
we just
Oh, okay. So we just got a
of course.
API resources.
Grab.
K.
Get.
You dating.
Suspicious.
Let's
try validating.
But is is is
QCTL
still working? Maybe something happens to be
Yeah. We've lost everything there.
Oh, maybe it's down again.
Maybe it got
killed or something like the
what about XD? Yeah.
Oh,
XD got killed again. So something is killing
probably at city. Alright. Let's see what happened
to at city.
I held our log.
At city.
Yeah. Same thing.
Received terminate terminating signal shutting down.
We saw that the
Chrome tab
wasn't there. So something is
we didn't see if we have any Rawkode,
maybe bots that could be killing a city
on the on the
Yeah. It could be a Rawkode.
From within the cluster. Right?
I just quickly I guess we need to
restart, yeah, we need to restart
the Qubelet again so it starts at three
again and see if there's anything on the
cluster that could be clean.
Yeah. We do need to restart.
Yeah. Just to get things taken along. I'm
just doing a quick scan of the process
table.
Oh, people are super sneaky.
Let's do oh, you've restarted. Okay. So we
just need to do the wait. Yeah.
Is this new?
It's not right.
No. It's four minutes old.
What did I wait. What did I yeah.
I restarted the Qubelet.
Let's
go to the static manifest directory and and
just modify the file.
Yeah.
I mean, the the modified timestamp in all
of them, I don't know if that's a
red heading to
get this or, you know, changes have actually
been made here.
So shall we change anything here?
You could just
sat there Maybe an annotation? Yeah. Yeah. Just
show a label on it.
Let's see.
Yeah. There is. Okay. That's why we've got
an API server hopefully running.
One thing we noticed was it never got
healthy. Right? So
let's check out the probes on that entity
manifest.
Oh, you're right. Yeah.
Okay.
So k get bot slash a.
We could just open the entity manifest in
front of unless it's done by a mutating
because we had so many different ways to
fuck up our cluster.
Yeah. Do you do you wanna check the
mutating admission workbooks first to see if there's
anything weird there? Yeah. I'm worried if that's
gonna cause the crash.
Let's say that.
Okay. Gets.
I'm gonna go with mutating first because I
think it
there we go. Yeah. There's something with there
which shouldn't be there.
So
what you are thinking of is that maybe
he trigger something when we try to access
a specific resource at SkinnyFTT?
Well, yeah, because we've now just lost our
API server.
Oh.
So whenever we try to access a new
training new taking webhook, we just
lose the the
STD.
It appears that way, doesn't it?
We still got an API server. Do we
still have it's still running. Oh. Was that
intermittent? Wait a minute.
Oh, it's it's here again.
Okay. Let's try that AIDA again.
Okay.
What what is it doing? It's
running.
STD. See? Yeah. Object selector
component not in STD.
Let's just delete it. I don't trust it.
Well, of course, don't. Yeah. Think.
Gone. Okay. What about validating?
Okay.
Nothing there. Okay.
Let's see the SD bots to see if
they make sure that the
I I think STD Yeah. Stuff right there.
STD is now held for. It's
passed in its probe. No. That that's for
DNS. Right?
No. STD.
The it's CD cluster, it's it's okay. It's
ready, and it seems to be
Yeah. But that wasn't doing that before. So
now I think we need to focus our
energy on this controller manager. Oh,
sounds good. Oh, and their scheduler's down too.
So
Oh, they are okay. Let's see the yeah.
Let's describe the
the pod. And
we still need to check our DNS.
Well, DNS should be ideally, it should be
fixed, I believe. Right? But let's check the,
yeah, the controller first.
I'm just gonna quickly jump in here. Yep.
Sounds good. Let's rule that out. So Do
we need to recreate those? Oh, no. Yeah.
Now it's running. Nice. DNS is fine. Let's
focus on the controller manager.
Nice. Yeah. Let's let's check the healthiness
post there.
Thanks for joining us, Walid.
Oh, I'm in there.
Yeah. You're in there. Nice.
Nice. Good call.
Just because I see that there call. Yeah.
Okay. Very good. Okay. So
if we Let's see the the
deployment of the controller manager c or the
the the demo set.
Oh, it's all healthy. I I
and the controller manager logs here, there's a
reference to that. I'm using webhook. I think
that was just causing Oh, that's issue with
yeah. It was causing issues.
Shall we check the deployment now to see
if it's
we have connectivity?
Yes.
Good call.
I don't know if the DNS
actually fixed it.
Let's find out.
Yep. Nice.
Okay. Let's try that. Bump it. Yep. Yeah.
I'll give you the honors. Thank
you, sir.
Yeah. There it is.
Image.
No homes now. Please delete.
Container creating. Welcome, Adrian. No. We are not
breaking things. We are fixing things,
hopefully.
Since we're running, if you can do the
honors and check the
port forwarding Okay. Just to make sure. You
know?
So, Billy, is it
is it something that we are missing besides
the DNS and the
mutating webhook?
Because we we don't know if this is
gonna go down again. Maybe SCD is gonna
get another
terminating theme of, and we could be missing
something. And we could assume, yeah, that seems
to be running. Yep. This is is well,
from what I could tell, you know, we've
deployed our upgrade. We've browsed our application. It's
speaking to post graders delivering quotes. The video
doesn't work because Firefox doesn't support the codec.
I need to fix that. But I think
this cluster is operational.
See, to me,
that was a,
like,
a rest from the other one
so far.
Yeah. Those mutated webpics are brutal. Like, there's
so much carnage can be caused by those
things that is wild. Yeah.
We don't have anything fancy here.
Yes. I guess that's pretty much it here.
Do you want to, like, go back to
the other one for a few minutes? I
have a twenty one minutes until my next
meeting. So
I don't know. Let's let's see if we
can find the honk. Belly, if we messed
anything to do that, there's no
and we're back on seventeen. Feel free to
join the session. We're looking for a container
d honk.
Container d honk.
Don't even, I don't even know where to
look.
We did kill
service key. Oh, have I lost Marcus again?
2017.
Yeah. So that's old.
No binaries have been
modified or injected except for key, which I'm
just gonna remove.
And that wouldn't give us a honk.
Bye. I'm back. Hey. Looking back.
Yeah. Just a little bump here. I'm gonna
sneeze you. Belly has informed us that we
we did miss one thing,
but they've seen it on our screen multiple
times.
Oh,
okay. Maybe on the money test or yeah.
But the deployment was working though. Right? So
does it mean that the execution will go
down again, really, eventually? Or
Yeah. Let us know.
Okay. Let's
let's think about this hung. I I have
to remove that key binary. We don't need
it there. Don't care about the system deserviced.
The binary is gone.
I started
the LS here by time. I just want
to know if there was anything else modified.
Doesn't appear to be.
Has to be You will join there.
There's nothing called Hong. Oh.
Which I was hoping I was hoping for.
What else?
I
mean, I'm I'm really tempted just to go
for the sledgehammer here and see dash how'd
you do it? Linux
find modified files.
There's a way to find like everything modified
from twenty four hours.
That's the one.
Plus the one.
Marcos.
Maybe that was a bit too
too wide scoping. Shit.
Three d active I'm
joining now. I'm there.
I've kind of broken that session, I think.
Oh, okay. It's not responding?
No. My faint was a little bit too
wide scope. So I think we'll need to
spin up a new one there.
Sounds good.
I'll try that again, but this time I'll
just target
take a look at user.
What could it be?
Well, it looks like
potentially installed to Linux headers, which means I'm
thinking of a compiled binary on this device
somewhere.
It leads me to think just because we've
the kernel headers potentially
oh, it's doing that weird thing.
Yep.
I'm gonna run that one more time but
grab dash v
l and
grab dash Module. Modules.
He'll start
No. I was hoping for more.
Yeah. I'm not I mean,
please don't tell me that there's some weird
kernel module doing some
funky stuff here. I don't see any. Should
we check the bash history and see if
he's been sneaky enough to remove it?
We can. Let's do it.
Chrome tab dash r. Maybe there's a oh,
system d.
Well, that was us.
No.
But not the enable. Not the system d
enable.
This was me just before we went live,
which means the only commands that Sasha has
left us here
are these.
So he removed the cron tab and then,
yeah, he added the k binary?
So I'm gonna assume he's cleaned up the
bash history and just left a few things
in to laugh at us.
Okay. Where's the honk? Where is the honk?
It's it's weird that the
I we couldn't find any container container reconfigurations
that could
be causing and why why is it that
that only the first time the the container
fails and then when it restarts,
it comes back to life. No? So something
I I like to do is to stop
actually, it's quite sledgehammerly,
though, but it's to stop container d as
a service and run it manually. Should we
try that?
Yep. That's good.
Because it it means that we can run
it in debug mode.
Sounds good.
Okay.
So why don't we pop open another shell
and scale clustered up to 30 again and
see
if we get anything in the container log.
Oh, you'll need to pop open another
Yeah. Yeah. Another tab. Yeah. Sounds good.
Want me to do it, or do you
wanna do it?
I'll I'll do You You could just join.
Yeah. You go for it since I'm just
joining. Yeah. Okay. It seems like the teleport
UI is a bit heavy, and it takes
some time to download it. Yeah. It's here.
Okay. So I'm gonna do alias
k, cube control,
export,
and I'm gonna edit the deploy,
clustered,
Find replicas.
Sorry.
I just joined.
Runtime.
Yeah. Run
container error.
Nothing on container d.
So it must be an external process.
It's kinda
where where I'm Yeah. The the weird part
is that it it gets rescheduled,
and we don't have any mutating webhooks or
any
the manifest weren't changed also.
Okay. Let's go that back down.
Checking the mounts, see if they have been
messed with. Maybe we're not even looking at
the right static manifest directory or
I don't know.
One thing that I would love I I'm
gonna create create a session on the on
the one of the workers.
I would really like to know if there's
maybe we can run container d on debug
in the waters instead of on
the because you you did it on the
on the control plane. Right?
Yeah. Maybe we're just looking on the wrong
machines. Although, I'm pretty sure we did see
the
the adder across
a whole bunch of nodes. I lost the
history here now.
Yeah. It's gone. Oh, wow. Okay.
Alright. Let's join worker d case
seven.
I created a session there. Yep. Alright. Okay.
I don't wanna join your session. I will
flash your IP address unless you're okay with
that.
Yep. Sounds good. Alright. Okay. I will join
your session.
Oh, yeah. It should be the last one
I yep. Yep.
So we were
stopping continuity. Right? Yeah.
Yeah. We'll stop it. We'll run it with
logs level debug. We'll scale up the deployment
and see if we can see anything. Container
d
log level
equals debug.
Oh, look.
Oh, yeah. No.
Is this expected?
Oh, it's oh, it's starting the the container
server. Right? Yeah. Oh, yeah. Okay.
Alright. So that I'll give it a second
to settle.
Oh, wait. Why was there who am I?
What do you see? I see that who
am I run. Yeah. Here. Who am I?
And that's normally Oh, what is this? Something
nice containers don't often run who am I,
I would say. But
but this just looks I think it's just
Rawkode and Seth.
I can tell.
It's the number of PGs I wonder.
Okay. Let's see. Has it settled? No.
It's still sped out quite a bit, isn't
it? Alright.
Yeah. But it it is doing some weird
stuff. Right? Accepting I I do think so.
Yeah.
Yeah. It doesn't doesn't seem to be, like,
a happy container. The
what is this big chunk of
JSON?
Seems like a
container. Nothing fancy here.
Rank
election.
Kraken,
Octopus,
How's the control manager?
Control manager? Oh, then oh, no. There's no
debugger, but it's in error.
Yeah. All the ports seem to be okay
in control manager at least.
Okay.
I'm stumped. Yeah. All the demons that are
are happy.
It's it's weird that that it is complaining
that much. Right? So something's definitely
Bogdan thinks it is
just liveness probes running, which
I mean, who am I as a liveness
probe? I guess so. Perhaps.
Okay. Let's let's kill container d.
The other thing we can do with container
d is print the config.
Oh, you're right. Yep.
Don't.
Continue to get that solved.
I'm not that familiar
with
this. Handbook. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. There there could
there could be some crazy stuff here.
Well, at least I see Linux isn't enabled.
That would have fucked me up.
Default runtime,
run c.
I I think this is
this is fine.
You don't see any honks in there? I
I see I mean, I have regret for
honks, but I see
see no honks. That.
Create failed honk unknown.
Let's see on the
yeah. Disability. Right?
Let me see system.
System d.
Yeah. Nothing here, bro.
I'll leave container d.
These are only the error logs
from previous containers.
Create sandbox field.
Yeah.
This is the error for the audience. This
is the error that we're getting.
The first time only happens the first time
when we are trying to run a
container
in these nodes, and then it goes away.
So the
when when the scheduler reschedules the bot on
the on the same note, it just starts
It works. Successfully. So,
yeah, so it it is very weird, actually.
Is there a
I mean, our application is working. We did
upgrade it.
So
Yeah. Yeah. It's
just one of those subtle breaks and that
the if it wasn't for that honk, I
wouldn't even be looking anymore.
But the fact that the honk is there.
The yeah. There's teleport of the Excuse me.
The the cluster is working. Thank you very
much. Our application is upgraded, and we've browsed
it.
There's just a there's just a wild goose
on the list, and we don't know where.
Yeah. It seems like there's some
really
low level stuff happening here in all that.
Well, could be simpler though, but it's
very difficult to spot. Yeah. We we we've
seen this with with other clusters. There are
subtle things that breakers put in that don't
really have the same effect that they thought
and the cluster kind of works but kind
of doesn't. And those are really difficult for
us as fixers to find a debug because
if we don't have a symptom,
really difficult to work out what is breaking
it.
Yeah.
This this okay.
System, Cubelet. We we checked this one. Right?
Yeah. We did.
Yeah. No no such thing here. Yeah. And
Barley, Cubelet, we have to check it.
Cloud provider external.
Container runtime remote.
Perfect. The Container d.
Yeah.
Continue. Yeah.
I I can cut this one. So because
it's a socket.
I mean Oh, maybe there's
there's a plug in here in the cubelet.
This is a roof. Yeah.
Well, that's for sure. I mean, you never
know. Right? No. Nothing here. I mean I
don't know, man. I don't have idea. Just
because I know the space that Sasha works
in, I have to assume this is a
BPF program with something in the kernel to
reject the syscalls to create the sandbox, but
it only does it randomly on the first
one.
I just don't know how we'd be able
to pull out the BPF programs to see.
I'm not I I think BPF is awesome,
really really cool, but working with it day
to day is not something I have experience
with. So I think what's Yeah. Leave that
one up to his report and see what
Tom fucker he was up to. But
Yeah. I don't even know where to look.
If if it is a EBPF programs, then
forget about it. I tried checking the the
external module, but EBPF is like a completely
different stuff. Right? So Yeah. And he installed
the Linux kernel headers. So, I mean, that's
gotta be a telltale. Oh,
yeah. That makes sense.
Alright. You know what? Our applications are working.
We did upgrade them. We did browse to
them. Mission almost successful. We missed one thing
on Bellies. We missed one thing on Zashes.
We will get the breaker reports in the
next few days.
I think we'll call that I'm gonna call
it a win.
Yeah. Same thing. I'm gonna call it a
win. I'm gonna have, like, a, like, a
sweet no. No. Not a sweet. Like, a
sour
flavor on on the cake, but it's okay.
Mean,
we managed to do it. Applications
are running. Clusters are not restarting. I mean,
we're happy. Right?
I am definitely happy.
We got a couple of final comments. Papa's
just install.
Alco SysTick. Of course. Yeah. We could install
stuff to that for better visibility. We're not
going to that now.
No suggested LS mod. We did list all
the kernel modules. We did CBPF,
but it really difficult for us to work
any deeper than that. And we're now at
a stage where it's the
the end of our session. So
how is that, man? Did you enjoy it?
It's been a pleasure. It's been a pleasure
to me. So really looking forward to the
next episode and to read the the post
breaking
modem, if you wanna call it that way,
to see what I what what what do
we miss.
Alright. Well, thank you very much for joining
me today. I think we did really well.
We got both our applications upgraded. Like I
said, I'm calling that a win. Thank you
to Sasha, thank you to Billy for, you
know,
for the breakers and the factors to you,
Marcos. Right? This this takes time. Breaking a
cluster is not always a it's not something
that you can just say, yes, I'm gonna
do without allocating time to it. So thank
you very much, breakers. And Marcos, thank you
for setting aside time to join me today.
To everyone else Thank you, baby, for inviting
me. My pleasure. And to everyone who watched,
have a great day. We'll be back next
week. I'll see you then. Thanks a lot.
Bye. See you the next one. Take care.
Have a good one.